hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to death like awakening oh
god I'm in a book o demon senses your
moves okay
flutes this button to start the game I
don't know if I want a flute [ __ ] anyway
I wait where's my hands man's here my
hands on no my hands are not on where's
my hands okay oh there I am okay but
touch it Looch oh all right so this game
promises demons that sense my movement
which is oh I hate it already oh I hate
this wise one a controller still oh okay
oh it's a Naruto run scooch
just got a row row row the boat here all
right I gotta find seven sigils so it's
a very slender man ask
I love the rowing of the boat kind of
like what Oh - hold up oh it's all oh I
get it
oh ha ha ha ha oh that's a clever
mechanic oh I'm not moving I'm not move
I'm not moving Oh God ok alright don't
move I get it alright I need to not move
I get it when you tell me to not move
you know I don't move that's what I do
wow that was not fun dupa dupa do know
oh my god do-do-do-do-do-do-do top oh I
hate this I'm not moving okay bye ha ha
we did it all over this day oh hi oh hi
hello hmm okay bye see ya okay I'm gonna
go this way then Aleut don't add up
I'll add it no no I'm swinging in my
arms I'm gonna swing this one cuz don't
wanna Oh
cause a ruckus okay all right all right
y'all okay all right I see Oh whoo I
think I recognize this area from pub G
any sigils in here any sigils I should
know about
looky all right continuing on my way
just old swingarm over here that's
that's me Oh heard something but I don't
know what so I'm just gonna keep swing
swung in until the day is done
ooh pretty architecture I like oh the
Sistine Chapel okay all right that makes
sense
all right here you hear you clang clang
clang I have this weird device from the
future here watch a shadow puppet see
this is Jesus and this is also Jesus so
Jesus and Jesus too came in anyway I'm
gonna move on now before I cause more
sacrilege and make the ghost angry huh
yeah that's right okay I didn't see a
sigil so I'm just gonna no no no no
later dude dude although I'm going
through the woods daughter D hope I'm
facing the right way cause I can't see
bloody [ __ ]
Dex La Belle Lupo
nothing it was just my imagination
walking through the woods and getting
really disoriented mmm
that's not good oh my things is
vibrating real good hello hello okay
all right oh yeah I don't like that
where am i where am i facing by the way
where am i oh I'm completely wrong scoot
you're over there okay you're this tree
okay go hi
tree maybe if I just dance like that'd
be enough to suggest like some movement
cool all right that'll that stewing it
okay get a little dance this way do the
third love to do the Lizzy along dun da
da da dee this is terrifying this is
awful I hate this a lot mmm yeah this is
unpleasant
Paul boy yeah this is what I would call
very scary oh yeah yeah yeah
I don't see you know god damn said Jules
I don't even know the Frick frack and
sigils look like a wheat field nothing
good ever happened in a wheat field okay
all right well this is a change of pace
not only in my walking style but in the
wheat field I'm going through Oh wheat
field cuz that's what I wanted to do ooh
dog [ __ ] was that someone talking to me
about my wheat field stroll huh someone
got a problem with it okay I'm really
gonna go for it everybody close your
eyes for a bit it's about gonna get real
weird no that's no faster huh row row
row your boat gently down the Trib
there ain't no oh well oh there ain't no
I was about to say there ain't a sigil
to be found but I think I found a sigil
hang on let's see what's in here sure
it'll be a warm and welcoming and make
me feel good about myself
hello ah
that looks bad okay I'll just go in on a
duel nope you know I'm a I'm on whoa hey
essential whoa I I blacked out for a
second there apparently I got a sigil
though what's in here what's in this
bloody box of despair huh
nothing hopefully okay well there okay
it does not want me to look at that
sigil huh said y'all okay I got one
all right good for me okay on to the
next one oh hi okay
hi oh this is a bad thing ah okay oh hi
hi hole I'm not moving I'm not moving
I'm not moving I'm not moving
oh god I almost okay all right everybody
hold on I'm feeling some vibrations
every time I know it's closed my
controllers vibrate that's bad
my vibrant the vibrations have stopped
gonna move now hmm oh that's me okay oh
hi hello oh you like to scamper don't
you oh you like this guy oh you're real
Stamper e oh look a truck reminds me a
slender man oh it's getting real shaky
Oh No it's as simple as that
it's just a stroll in the woods that's
all it is that's all it'll everybody's a
sigil I think I see oh I bet it is
oh god damn it oh my god that is
terrifying that is Fric frakking
terrifying yeah all right I'm gonna go
one more time I'm gonna go one more time
I think I can do this a little better
you got to follow the road is the thing
you have to follow the road if you
follow the road you'll have the mohei
controller you have a much better chance
of surviving
where am i I am in know where I am I'm
in the void apparently I broke the game
I think okay oh there I am okay there I
am okay so there's the road and I'm
gonna go to the road and I'm just gonna
stick on that road like glue no reason
to go off the road and no reason to get
scared it's just a simple creature
that's stupid and dumb and probably
extremely ugly yep that's it that's all
there is
okay alright just me alone in the woods
alone nobody beside me just me all alone
here alone that's me alright okay ooh
what are you I can't read that but it
looks like something from pub G as well
hi hello where'd you go
okay
okay all right got it go up the stairs
into the building where I don't think
you can follow me I learned a signal hmm
oh my controllers are shaking up a storm
get that rope I'm looking at you
mmm looking at you so good mmm
bonk okay whoa six more to go son of a
[ __ ] you don't scare me
you scare me okay all right that's
that's the opposite of good
Oh No okay bye
yeah oh my god what blind okay just
gonna skedaddle away skedaddle in away I
miss good darling away that's what I do
and that's what I say I mask a dog went
away
Weehoo Oh wah foo
ah yes I've entered the area of the dead
trees that's awfully Pleasant for me I'm
super happy about how they're all dead
or reminds me of what I'm gonna be in a
few seconds oh is that a graveyard I
hope so I pray oh I wish upon a star
that it's a graveyard oh all my prayers
have been answered it's a graveyard Oh
frabjous day
Callooh Callay well I don't like those
sounds but you know it's alright
can I get in there sir said the winner
anybody know sigil really really no sir
oh there she blows
God are you God come to Papa hey how's
going you're doing great okay - I got to
go okay you know you can stop at a
moment now the moaning is really not
becoming of you I really swings wrong in
it now whoo this feels natural it feels
like natural movement okay ah nice horse
how's your dick nice balls on you
Oh
nothing okay never mind then I was lying
about all that I just compliment people
Oh No
okay all right nothing here uh on my way
out the door with more I'm gonna go
around the perimeter until I loop fact
that's why I'm gonna do oh it's the
truck the one I died at before remember
that one guys
oh yeah it's fun dying here look no said
July there oh you know what that's fine
didn't really want one anyway I'm gonna
check the truck maybe it's in whoa there
she blows I see you hang on
got a really skadoodle around this thing
and swamp Oh ah it looks like a truck
odometer I like that
okay scoot lead ooh ah no I am moving no
oh it's gonna go this way
oh boy oh I love this
damnit oh [ __ ] you ah [ __ ] anyway that
is death like awakening that is really
fun good mechanics they're very scary
the whole not moving thing that's really
nice so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought of
this one down the comments below I might
finish this one but it is a little
disorienting it's a little nauseating
not something that you could play for a
super extended period of time but still
very scary so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]